so it's 4:30 and I guess we should get
going my name is Craig Wright and I
along with my colleague Lucas Winfred
and my colleague Linda Larmour we have
the honor of being the I guess co-chairs
of our online initiative here at Yale
this is the fourth of these that we have
done this year you may be somewhat
surprised by somewhat small attendance
here today but we are much more robust
than it might actually appear because we
were Lucas and I were joking and not
joking commenting on as we came in that
perhaps the reason there's so few people
here is that everybody is actually
watching these online and in point of
fact because we post these and because
Lucas and his group are kind enough to
divide them in the various segments that
we have particularly as we had last time
with the various presenter school
nursing and others involved that it's
possible to come in and just watch what
you want to watch that we had over 5,000
hits on the the one that we had on
December December 2nd so that's that's
pretty encouraging and maybe that's the
way people get their information these
days so here we are
Harkness Hall wlh room 116 I spend a lot
of time teaching this room and as I look
around and today we are talking about
online education in the future of
education around the world it amuses me
to stand in a classroom like this with
hardwood floors fixed seating and to
think about how I would like to engage
technology so I had this substance here
and it is this is slate and I have this
other kind of substance it is chalk and
I could go up here and I could write
various times of symbols and signs and
that's exactly the way they've been
doing it for more than a thousand years
in the educational process in the West
chalk on slate and that's the way we all
did it when I first came here at you
know but now things are changing
changing in very interesting kinds of
ways so that's what we want to find out
more about today so we have five
presenters this is an opportunity for us
to show you what we are doing with
online education and for you to come to
us with your ideas so that we can in
fact begin to explore them and begin to
implement them and that's really what's
going on here is the - it's a two-way
dialogue and I guess that by definition
that's what a dialogue is what a silly
thing to say a two-way dialogue so in
any event we're going to we're going to
start out here and we have some
wonderful information coming to us first
of all from those that run our summer
session we I'm not entirely sure I think
it's probably because of Linda's good
judgement here we actually started out
with one portion of our online program
what we are calling the spock's
exclusively in the summer format yes
we've had open Yale courses those are
the the MOOCs the first-generation MOOCs
and now we've gone on to the Coursera
MOOCs but we also had this other
initiative going and that was a wise
decision to put these in the summer
program because it gave us the
opportunity to to work in a very
controlled environment to experiment but
experiment within borders in a way and I
think we got a lot out of that process
that process has grown it's grown under
the excellent leadership of the Dean
William who Bree and Dean who Bree is
here and he's going to talk about this
as well well as he is Richard Collins
who works in implementing the technology
for so having said that let me turn
things over to Bill and Bill take it
away and tell us about what's on tap for
this summer so thank you again professor
right then it's a pleasure to be here
and I've got ten minutes
I'd like to split that time
between myself and and rich Collins and
I imagine we're taking questions at the
very end is that right so after each
presentation all right thank you so 10
minutes to present and then we'll have
some questions after that so again as
Craig said I'm bill Who Bri I'm the Dean
of Yale summer session I've been here
for about 20 years about 13 of that as
dean of the summer session I think to
start off with one of the comments that
Craig made in his introduction I think
in doing this in the summer he's right
to point to a kind of controlled
environment that I think used an
established model which included short
compressed but full credit courses we do
a regular Yale College course in five
weeks for full Yale credit these courses
are taught by Yale faculty to a great
extent and it's the model that we've
been using for about 35 summers now but
beyond that the summer of course is also
a time of great mobility as we know for
our own Yale students they're off around
the world doing all sorts of exciting
things
some of them will remain here in New
Haven to take courses on campus during
the summer and others will be all will
be doing all sorts of other things off
campus as we can easily imagine online
courses have certain advantages
certainly with in terms of mobility and
being able to access these kinds of
courses and our Yale faculty from around
the world so I do want to spend just a
minute or so on on really I think the
basics it's important first try to
understand what it is that we're trying
to accomplish why it looks the way that
it does is based on the goals the
purpose for which in fact we created
these online courses they don't do all
things they're not designed to they're
designed to do some very specific things
again very much in the model of the way
that we teach and what we teach
during the summer in ye'll summer
session so about four years ago it was a
little bit more than that that I was
asked I would say almost challenged to
come up with a way that courses could be
taught during the summer online but a
couple of things had to be in place and
so I think it's important to again
recall what the focus is first of what
we do in the summer
and second of what we do in the summer
online these are courses for Yale
college credit now having said that
there are already a lot of things that
that entails they have to be approved
for credit and we have a mechanism in
Yale College to do that it's called a
course of study committee all summer
courses including courses taught online
have to go to the course of study
committee they have to be approved by
the committee and ultimately they're
approved by a vote of the Yale faculty
so these are courses that are accredited
in exactly the way that all other summer
courses are they carry exactly the same
credit which is to say it's Yale college
credit it's not transfer credit and
they're taught in five weeks again we
have some experience with how to do that
and we had a model that we could base
that on people I'll be quite honest I
think felt comfortable with that I mean
we knew what that meant we knew what it
meant to a credit of course during the
summer and in fact that such a course
had to have certain characteristics
course of study committee is looking for
certain characteristics in any course
departments academic departments
obviously play an important role in
determining what is to be taught in the
summer and who is going to be teaching
that during the summer and so this was
no different so we went to the
departments we went to faculty who we
thought might be interested it's again
important to emphasize that all of our
summer courses online again as with most
of our courses in the summer are taught
by Yale faculty
we think that's an important part of the
credit
in fact that's offered so that a student
who takes one of these courses knows
that this course is going to be taken by
other Yale students for credit towards
their degree and is going to be taught
by Yale faculty as they would teach a
course during the semester or during the
summer for credit the emphasis is on
seminar learning now I think I could
make a broad statement and not be too
far off to say that in Yale College and
having taught in Yale College for almost
20 years
I think the seminar experience is at the
heart of that educational experience for
our young undergraduates we have large
lectures with fantastic lecturers but
Yale students also know that that
experience around a big table with 10 or
maybe even up to 18 of their fellow
students is in fact the kind of seminar
experience that they equate with a Yale
education I think that's an important
factor in the development of the
Freshman Seminar program Yale College
wanted to make sure that freshmen had
that kind of seminar experience with
Yale faculty so that small class
learning that happens around a big table
was something we wanted to try to do
around a big virtual table the
interaction with faculty I think if you
asked any Yale college student what is
it that makes their education here
unique and exciting I think they would
say their interaction their close
interaction around a big table with Yale
faculty we wanted to see if we could
recreate that in a live environment and
then finally we wanted some room we can
often do this in the summer to look at
what else could be done online or what
is this balance between synchronicity
and a synchronicity how much can we do
live how much can we do with other sorts
of tools that would be available so
here's a quick overview another slider -
I'll turn it over to rich
20:11 we tried out two courses
Craig was one of our very first
instructors we did a pilot not for
credit but simply some willing guinea
pigs may I say who were willing to try
this and we just needed to see if this
could even be done could we actually get
people I hate to say a Skype like
environment I think it's actually richer
than that but in a live video
environment who could have a meaningful
discussion around an academic topic we
thought at the end of the first summer
that we could do that the next year we
had eight courses we did a lot of
assessment and surveys both of the
faculty and the students to try to give
us a sense in the very first year is
this something that Yale faculty and
students consider to be Yale quality are
we providing an educational opportunity
of course for credit that in their
estimation is equivalent to what they
would otherwise take here in the summer
for credit or potentially even during
the academic year the next year we have
thirteen courses we have had more and
more Yale faculty interested in this
medium interested in teaching online
seeing what this feels like what it
works like and I think we've had
continuing success as more and more
faculty have tried it always with
slightly different pedagogical tools
maybe slightly different approaches to
their own courses as it should be this
coming summer we have 19 courses offered
online for credit
I'll let you simply look at the slide I
think simply what we're trying to say it
is a compressed format students meet two
or three times online at the same time
there is an asynchronous synchronous
blend there are a lot of things that you
can do interactively that are not all at
the same time that can be useful and
again we have we're listening to
feedback and so far so good
let me pass it on to rich who will take
us through a little bit more of what a
course looks like I probably ran over my
five minutes but rich Collins deal
summer session online program manager
let me back up just a bit so let's take
a quick look at what of course actually
looks like as bill mentioned these are
really a blend of asynchronous and
synchronous activity probably imagine
about almost a 50% split on the
asynchronous side we have captured
lectures that the students look at each
each week you can imagine over five
weeks the compression here is quite
heavy and the courses actually move
along really quickly so students have a
lot to accomplish within the first half
of a week and then before they move on
to the next half of the week
yes being lectures to look at the
advantage of streaming lectures is he's
the possibility of playing them back and
not just looking at the lecture once as
you would be ended up in the classroom I
was noting on the feedback that we
received last couple years that the
streaming recorded lectures was actually
one of the more positive feedbacks that
we received I was expecting it to be
more on the live side of it
but the students actually looked at
responded with almost equally positive
feedback with the you streaming lectures
the recorded lectures and these lectures
earlier Patrick in a classroom or the
faculty go out to the broadcast media
center and actually get recorded in
studio other HT prints activity many
online courses will have threaded
discussion but in in our format because
we're so compressed threaded discussion
usually needs about a week to play out
and we just don't have that time so
because we have such a heavy emphasis on
the live synchronous side we also don't
need we also use supplemental
screencasts which for example doesn't
keys economics course you he'll actually
use a Wacom tablet in Camtasia
supplement to his lectures so he is
lecturing in class writing on the board
and the camera is picking this up and if
there's any type of glitter on the con
the board what have you lost translation
on the board students can't follow as
well on the board what he's doing with
problem sets he has pan picked a number
of those problem sets to redo in asking
a Camtasia typer cun-cun cast
type recording and put that into LMS two
as a supplement to the student on the
synchronous side we have about three
hours or so of free live discussion each
week that's typically broken up over
about two days it's difficult to go a
full three hours a day so a Tuesday
Thursday hour and a half each day Monday
Wednesday that what have you the live
discussions is central to the program
the students have their reading they
have their reading responses or other
problem sets to do homework but really
the the live discussion time is the
culmination of
that week as you can see here here's an
example after this is an example from
2012 with Ellen lust
I picked this screen capture up because
she's actually from actually
so she is coming in as a guest speaker
with local subject matter expertise on a
given topic of course it's Middle East
politics so you can you can leverage the
technology for the students benefit the
other reason I chose this example is
because Ellen West he's not in my hand
and she's in actually in Tunisia so
that's a leveraging the technology to
provide opportunity to teach and provide
academic credit of students when both a
student and potentially the attacker
member is not even in in the end another
screenshot just wanted to point out to
various media from from the web you can
bring in PowerPoint presentations look
from locally you can bring in YouTube
Craig has done that extensively with
this music course and bring any music
parent a YouTube video of a concert so
this is the overall look and feel of the
watch to the class interact tool that we
use just about a hundred percent of the
courses this area in the middle scholar
stage students three single sign-on
under center through the
their names are automatically applied
what's unique about this instant this
this tool is it's an open mic system
there is no push-to-talk so everyone's
mics are open it is it is by no means a
replacement for a classroom but being
able to see everyone in one place with
an open and white you know it does have
a nice classroom feel because you are
utilizing that webcam the webcams from
the student their faces are fairly large
in the imaging you can get it you can
get a feel how they are understanding
the material so this is John Rogers an
open class
so benefits already mentioned a few of
these 2013 though we had students that
were taking courses from London Beijing
Brazil Spain Hawaii we also have faculty
that were away we had faculty from Paris
Brazil Oxford on the west coast the live
interaction component of our courses
provides a high degree of discussion and
interactions each day for each week
comparison in comparison to a nation if
in this course last two years I've
pulled students and the faculty and with
a question of if we reduce the amount of
interaction that we had in our courses
would you be favorable to take this
course again or teach this course again
70 to 80 percent of the students
basically rejected the idea of
minimizing or reducing the amount of
interaction that we
when trade-off with having this stuff of
this type of interaction or is this much
interaction is is how many how many
people you actually put the course how
many people can you actually interact
with you know a weekly basis live this
just limits how many students we can put
in and we capped around 20 so there's
always a trade-off for that high quality
high interaction with how many students
are in place in their courses that we
have that will have potentially higher
than 20 in enrollments we'll just had
another teaching assistant and have
multiple sections keep the section sizes
in addition students well realize it
reduction in cost they don't have to
travel you have travel saving rooms they
have savings of room and board so most
of our students that are not in the
native aren't our domestic most fair
noble number of them will be across so I
know graduate students I we have a lot
of opportunity for students to do course
development grading responsibilities for
each course and just general online
admin functions within the course
within mike within our summer sessions i
bring it across a student or two each
spring and summer Edmond
responsibilities challenges connectivity
the interaction that we require within
that course has a fair amount of I would
say the bandwidth in each course is very
heavy so it's very difficult for us to
ensure that all the students have it
make today they need
questions
she's fulfilled yes
I just a practical question um you
mentioned graduate students and we're
always interested in opportunities for
graduate students to develop their
teaching practice especially in online
forums do you do the graduate students
actually get to teach the classes or are
they sort of the assistant the admin to
sort of behind the scenes probably above
where the graduate students have
actually run the sections at times
within the course in cases where we have
courses that need multiple sections time
is actually split between a faculty with
various functions of course on campus as
well every course online so far has been
able to have a key as all the faculty
will attest it is very work intensive to
develop a course but the course online
and each of the course so that there are
also some of these functions some of
them having to do with the technology or
simply
we need some help in being able to
manage what's going on especially in the
live sessions graduate students the
public a lot with that but I know that
different courses they think
anything else